hello everybody welcome to another night
of chess on psychology
uh hope you are having a great night or
morning as i see from uh
australia wow i've actually never been
to australia i always wanted to
um oh mexico germany whoa all around
yeah great
i love germany um i've never been to
mexico but i've always wanted to
surprisingly from latin america i've
only been to panama
for just a weekend and brazil
i really should travel more um gmb
is to sleep right up here let me risk
by rotating the camera a little to
show the fourth ball
oh he's actually looking hello
alright so um we have
he has graced us with his eyes so
um we have that too and let's see what
else
ah yeah i today i figured out that
i am not done with the semester i i got
feedback paid from my paper and it was
painful so
you will most likely hear me vent about
that for
today a little bit and
i really thought i was done with my
semester i was quite happy
but besides that i'm having a pretty
chill week um
i took a uh diagnostics mcat yesterday
that was extremely painful for those of
you who
are already in med school or sharing my
journey of being pre-med and trying to
make it to my school like
guys i have no idea how that's gonna
work out like at this point
i'm just glad i still have like three
and a half months uh four months to just
study three and a half months but yeah
it's very scary
but um so i i was looking at some
chess recently uh surprised
and i kind of found um
i realized that i haven't really talked
too much about olivine
in our lessons so i kind of wanted to go
ahead
and do a few of his masterpieces
at least in my mind he might not
consider these masterpiece but in my
mind these are really great chests
so yeah um
i yeah peachy i don't know if you guys
remember last week pc had
some little sniffles and so i got some
like
medicine and everything but also at the
same time
i had to crank up the heat in my room
so much that i'm just basically walking
around like it's a sauna
he's sneezing stops though so it worked
things we do for our cats
ah brian um oh yeah i do want to visit
canada too actually one of my high
school friends just moved there so that
was also pretty cool to
keeping keep track of open book
exams i have a in all my classes except
that one paper that is just
really um i don't really know
what is the right way of saying it
besides
she's like such a nice polite teacher
but at the same time she's not really
like i wish she would give me like real
feedback instead of
just i'd like uh yeah yes it's a
struggle but i'm glad she's giving me
another chance to revise it she's not
just giving me a
horrible grade so yeah i got that going
too
um yeah uh yeah so oyvin everybody's
doing good
how do i not blunder i mean depending on
the position i do
all right so i kind of want to go ahead
and get started with these two
games because i'm quite excited about
them uh also whoa
no no wrong wrong quick so yes this was
actually a game that was played
in 1937
and it was their sixth match game so
keep that in mind as well and
yeah i think this was the historical um
i mean i don't think this was the
greatest game of the match but this is
the one that i kind of always liked but
anyways i've also um it's been a while
since i looked at
elephants games for purpose of comparing
which one is better so
he's definitely yeah he's such a great
brain ah
whoa we got some jumpy jumpy all right
oh my goodness how do i oh okay
i got it all right let's just go ahead
and start looking at the game a little
so it was also kind of funny for me how
in this position like this is such an
uncommon position like
you don't really see these type of
openings or this type of chest being
really played
in um high level chest that often
and yeah i agree it was kind of a
surprise but
at the same time i think bishop c4 is
another
weird slash just awkward surprise
because right now i think white could
just like develop and have a
pretty pleasant position you got the
center your bishop is still attacking so
if you were to like play bishop d3 let's
say take
potential take b5 i kind of like white
nothing wrong with it
uh you have a strong bishop yeah i mean
you gave up a pawn but this
i mean that's kind of the deal with any
gambits right
so um i kind of get why this
is interesting but taking on c4
take on d4 now you gotta also move your
knight
so question um
what should you do right now so why to
move what do you think you should do
so let me get the ipad a little closer
so i can actually
read the chat and don't have to just
keep moving around
okay 92 interesting but um
just because i said you have to move the
knight doesn't mean you have to move the
knight
you could just keep thinking about what
else if there is anything else
so i see a lot of my issues oh i see a
queen apps real quite interesting trying
to do intermediate moves
um ah
i see a knight f3 exactly exactly that's
that's what i was waiting for you guys
to um tell me so knight f3 is the
is a very interesting way because if you
were to take it now bishop takes f7
king d7 but how do you think white would
continue
uh this did not happen in the game which
is very interesting as well because
you would think that or oliver would um
you know try a little
aggressive stuff but just the idea of
knight f3 is so crushing
well keep in mind if you were to play
bishop g5 knight f6
and you have just gave up this knight
for basically nothing
so you can't just play bishop g5 you
need to play more aggressively
i mean you could potentially i guess
this
the problem is with even if you were to
play something like
take take and like i guess e5
there's still this like h6 g5 and you're
not gonna really be able to win
your piece back so you shouldn't go for
bishop g5 that's the point
i see in my d4 i see a
um bishop takes g8
hold on hold on if you were to um your
bishop g8 is interesting because
i'm assuming that you see bishop g5
check knight f6
so your solution is to take care of that
but careful because queen takes d1 is a
check
and that's gonna hurt
and then you're still gonna be a piece
down
i i don't think i've seen that oh i
think i see the correction of being
suggested by a few people
queen v3 is actually the interesting way
to go
it's kind of like the only way to try
and keep up some sort of attack
and um right now
black could just take on b2 um
you could take back and this is
something that
could potentially happen you would get
the piece back that you gave up on c3 a
while ago
and um you could just continue by
this two
take this guy and i think this is
this would have been very interesting
chances for both people
so that is i think that's something that
if you had kind of um if you were a
little
like prepared before the game that's
something you would have gone for
i agree bishop g8 is quite strange but
what what else are you gonna do if not
bishop g8
you you've lost the piece the queens are
getting treated so you have to do
something you don't want to
don't want to blow up your advantage so
you have to you mean you have to eat the
piece back
now taking back is not forced um black
would try and like throw a check in
there
you bring back the knight and uh still
queen of seven is happening so black has
to come up with some sort of way to
defend the king
and unfortunately now it's like you have
to take it take
back potentially take this guy
and you could just castle here
and both chances have pretty decent um
chess i mean decent bite nobody is like
that much better
but i think the problem was that
oywe was not ready for this idea
and so he did not really prepare for it
well
and keep in mind that if after queen b3
um i'm thinking is there anything
else that black could have done that
would have been interesting
maybe just might have six to try and
defend that
now you could just try to throw and
check over there
hold on can i take this without you to
check i kind of like this idea
ah queen b6 drawing the check
and c5 makes it slightly more unpleasant
i mean white still has a pretty decent
attack
but i think bishop v3 kind of makes the
most sense because you're stopping queen
b6 and you just want to do bishop c5
and make it very faithful so
yeah all right uh i think everybody in
chat they're kind of
with me if you're not just let me know
two pieces by rook so you uh i believe
you're talking about the position
oh how did i get here at
the end of this line well yeah that was
my point that you could take
and um take oh this is actually pretty
interesting
and this was an idea with bishop c5 i
didn't mention this because we didn't
really talk about bishop c5 but if you
were to take bishop c5 check
gotta take back and then you would
castle still attacking g8
and uh blue black has this squinish five
because if you take it then your queen
is kind of trapped you can't really take
on h7 anymore
so that was also another interesting
idea and black is doing much better just
because the queen is kind of
really doesn't have much to do however
let's go back
to where white did make the bishop c5
mistake
now if it was invited smart and took it
over here
check knight d2 and we talked about this
position
you could take honor 7 you could guest
castle um so i'm manny the point is that
yes if white were to give black like
five six
moves to develop like one move there two
moves there let's get the rook out let's
get the king summer safe if you give
back like five moves
and yeah what's going to be some real
trouble if black gets the chance to use
these bishops
and for that white needs to castle
immediately wisely to start attack
immediately
so it's all about the dynamic as as long
as the light has a chance to actually
start attacking the lagoon what should
be fine
any other questions for this line while
i'm
scrolling back to get to the main line
but i think the element of surprise is a
huge deal over here because
like knight f3 is not exactly the first
movie you think about right the first
movie i thought it was like where this
will probably have to bring the knight
back
there might be some checks involved then
i would probably do like a bishop d2 but
i don't really want to exchange those
bishops like i was thinking about
something like this
initially and then we end up with this
pretty interesting idea of oh wait i
could actually do knight to f3
uh i'm annie uh that's the point that
position
is very playable and very fighting for
both sides
um so compared to what happened in the
game
i like that position
so knight f3 and
here black made a horrible mistake of
playing b5
so black should have taken this and
black should have went to that line and
black should have gotten
to that position with two bishops as
manny suggesting that
it would have been pretty uh at least a
better fight very
very fighting game for both sides but
the problem now is b5 why do you think
b5 is a bad move
what do you think is wrong with b5
yeah i agree i think the first thing to
think about is okay can i take this
well to be fair the first thing we
should always think about is checks but
that check right now is not really doing
much for us
nice one i mentioned um yeah i don't
think at the moment is doing anything
for us so in order to
create more checks for the king we are
going to sacrifice this knight
and if take we would simply take oh
sorry my bad ouch ouch
we would simply play bishop d5
and that should be pretty painful that
truck is dropping first of all
and second of all this king is extremely
weak this pawn is going to fall
soon as well so that's another way that
could have been played um
so after knight takes b5 black realized
that well oops
i can't really take it because of my
poor rook so
black my bishop a6 now why to move what
do you think we should do
ah the cat is awake grooming himself
i think he likes the idea that his tree
is taller
than my chair and he has to sit up there
and like stare down at me
it's a very interesting combo
yeah i think coin beater is pretty
interesting great great job
so the thing with queen b3 ooh hi
high stake north queen a4 i would
recommend you to
be a little bit more cautious because
queen a4
now this is a fork and you don't really
have that idea with bishop
d5 is anymore and then you would have to
take it and you would just kind of give
up that knight and we don't really want
to do that
so be careful with that queen b3 is the
best because
now if you were to take it now i could
just even take over there and then queen
e6 is also coming so you have to run
through there
so i could even probably throw in that
chick this is just way too painful
we shouldn't really i mean black
shouldn't really give that chance to
white
so black should think about something to
you know keep this guy protected uh if
blue bishop takes p5 we have bishop f5
and just take this guy still trying to
create numerous attacks left and right
so um i believe in the game over play
queen to e7
now white to move what should we do this
is also a
very very interesting move like this
move
i did not find it myself like i
i think everybody can agree that this
position is better for white
but finding the exact move and that
sequence of moves
is a little yeah it could be a little
challenging
especially since right now your knight
is under attack
yeah i think if you played queen d7
knight e5 is a serious threat yeah
well you have to also keep in mind that
if you try to actually like distract
with like bishop g5
then there's this queen b4 that's coming
up and wants to exchange the queensland
we don't
exactly want to exchange queens
ah our show i beat you to bishop g5
uh even if e5 still queen comes to b4 so
the problem is queen coming to b4 and
wanting to exchange coins we don't
really
we shouldn't exchange queens as white at
least
um knight d4
um i'm still not a biggest fan but
knight d4
is doable nothing really wrong with it
even if you keep check
i could simply kind of just take and
play
bishop d2 i guess i could just do this
yeah because if you take i'll just take
with the knight knight defending the
bishop
i mean this is also a more pleasant
endgame for white as well
so this what this could do yeah this
could this could work to just simply
taking on d4 could potentially work
but it's not exactly the best level
so this is kind of funny actually bishop
d2
is a suggestion i it
it feels weird to me because first of
all what if take
yeah bishop d5 uh knight x oops knight
of six
um take on a8
white is much better but just like
thinking of bishop d2 as a way of
stopping queen b4
is a little bit just huh
yeah ah yeah castle
nice job rajimi castle is actually what
was
what happened in the game castle was
pretty nice
you just stop the queen before stop any
type of cleaning floor you just put your
king in a safe place
easy peasy um
the idea of knight d6 could
work but it's a little premature because
you're giving up so many pieces
take i'm assuming you want to take king
d8 i'm assuming you want to throw that
chick in there
um if knight comes out okay you got e5
uh but it's just king runs
keep keep in mind whoops not there queen
before also coming up
so probably you should do something with
the king over the castle
i mean this is also an interesting
attack don't get me wrong
if you played this it would become a
very interesting game there's nothing
wrong with it um but it's not the best
way to go about it so we
we always want to have that mix of
strategy and tactic
so if you were to just play like attack
attack attack with my d6
um you if you are a great tactical
player
you could probably pull this off but
ideally we want to be able to balance it
out
and have a mix of um
mix up both dynamic and strategy
so yeah that's why we would just go for
castle
uh after castle take
now what should we do we can't really
take on f7
and we could take on a in b5 but should
we
so why to move what to do
i see some ideas with bishop d bishop
takes f7
okay interesting bishop takes b5
and queen to d5 okay
and
so i see a lot of interesting ideas
knight d4
could maybe be worth considering bishop
of seven
is a flat out no because you just don't
have in any like you don't have pieces
to attack we should accept something
queen takes episode and then what
you're just like you're just a really
pickle
so you can't really do that
um brookty1 i see that you want to get
pieces out but you really do have to
take it
like you don't it's not it's not you
don't have that many choices here
unfortunately so you do have to take
and the thing is it takes okay now you
got queen deepak you're picking up the
rug
so great right
now let's go a little back and take a
quick look at knight f6 56 is actually
what happened in the game
so so the material is you're not really
behind
that much far behind in the material
just one pound if i'm not mistaken
actually never not even then because
that took he took back
my bad uh you could just be considering
this as a potential falling pawn
but that's even even better for you
because then you get to open up the king
right
so
exactly i'm manny yeah bishop b5 and we
just take back with the bishop
tada um i think that's ideally what
black would want to do but keep in mind
right now knight f6
is stopping your queen d5 which means if
it's black to move black is going to
take your bishop
so what do you think you should do
oh
oh hi spicy people
all right so i see a lot of interesting
ideas but i think the most logical one
that
i would go for is just push up c4 just
stop all the stop stopping all the um
weird ideas e5 could be interesting
i don't really see anything wrong with
it because you're the king of the center
you're just opening it up
that should be basic okay in chess
um i think this is e5 is pretty doable
too right now black's position is pretty
busted so
either bishop c5 or e5 wins as long as
you don't do something weird like bishop
f4 and then you lose your opponent you
lose your visual i think even
if even this works a little surprisingly
so yeah as long as you don't really make
like a humongous blender you should be
fine
even the sugar 4 actually works so never
mind on that
so but uh whoops bishop c4 makes a
little bit more sense your bishop job
here is done so let's just get it away
and go back to the original job
97 and now we can just pick this guy up
and it's so
funny because right now this is just
move 12
so in span of 12 moves or even is
completely
busted like really busted
like i can't even think how he would be
able to get out of it busted and he
didn't
so yeah
um
all right so in the game i wouldn't play
drug b but to be honest this game is
pretty much
done we just like i think we only have
very few moves like maybe um
about less than 10 moves to go over and
this is all super painful for black
what nationality is uh this game was in
1937 if i'm not mistaken so
i do not know i think oybe was from
netherlands whoa
sorry that just backfired whoa
oh that's not good i'm so glad i wiggle
one
um anyways
yeah so i think what is dutch uh
different to
my memory but if i'm wrong please feel
free to correct me i would love for that
yeah i mean i i've actually been
anywhere or i've
met i mean i haven't really seen anybody
in the last two weeks
so yeah now i got
i got uh she's happy she got me sneezing
we take turns but anyways uh so this was
kind of funny because
it was the i i believe he was the
reigning world champion at this point so
it would be kind of funny if you
just like resigned in 12 months so
uh yeah he didn't resign in 12 moves but
i mean
he's pretty lost so when you can play
like queen basically
back to d1 and still hold the plus five
you are super winning so he played queen
c2
uh let me just play 265 and it's just a
matter of technique
but honestly i believe even like knight
b3 is enough what about bishop e3
i kind of like bishop e3 too bishop to
have to be careful because there's nice
e5 but you can even just play b3 and
have fun
have a fun time uh in the game uh
alkine just played knight f5 knight g5
bishop f4
pinning that guy and
this is just super winning bishop of
seven take take
take and pick this up now attacking
there
there and the bishop is also defending
b2 this is
super painful and in the game
um all the time just played bishop d6
pushed upon this is just i mean i i
don't think i have enough words to
describe how painful this is but i'm
sure you can imagine
and yeah just take
take d5 and i believe here
finally or they resign which is i can
only imagine how painful this was
yeah um so back
i think the problem that oybiz started
facing was
first of all all the way back with
bishop takes c4 he probably started
getting super surprised
and after that this knight f3
kind of also got to him i would think so
and i think those are the two only like
real big moves
but yeah most of them both
and all kind of are super great chess
players
but somehow this didn't really get
work for them i mean um let me rephrase
that
uh even though they were super great
chess players and well i mean world
champions
oyber kinda got really busted in the
opening which is very
very fun for me anyways let's take
another
look at another game that alafine played
oh i'm glad you guys are enjoying but
uh basically as long as you're not
blundering something
serious in that opening in that end game
you should simply have been
pretty fine you shouldn't have
experienced any problems
so yeah i don't think that would have
been an issue
for that endgame just don't blunder
pieces
don't give free stuff as i usually
tell my students and until try to live
by that too
all right let's go ahead and do another
alpine game
this one is versus law scare and
um let's see when was this ah this was
1934 so
three years before the game uh with
whoops
three years before the game with jesus
oh my god why can't i speak all right uh
let's just go ahead
so normal opening so far
so far so good we still play these
okay am i like this bishop g5 so far so
good my d7
makes sense e3 duh
okay um so i want to ask a little
question
for example right now what do you think
what
where do you think white's pieces should
go where do you think black's pieces
should go
if you already play this opening feel
free to throw in hands or just give the
straight out answer
if you don't play this opening try your
best to figure out
what what should go where because that's
such a huge
thing in chess that just trying to
figure out
um where like where to place your pieces
i am not german if that's the question
i love germany i've been there a bunch
of times
the plan for all hinds defense is
i mean honestly i would say surprise
surprise
like just to surprise someone that's one
of the biggest thing because
i'm up front top of my head i don't know
any great chess player that
only plays the alpine defense so
i agree black should be trying to do
something in the queen side but that's
not kind of
the point it's more about um how
should you try and develop like probably
b6 bishop b7
and that shouldn't be too hard to figure
out
um i don't know my current rating and i
always get that
i grew up with feeder rating uscf
confuses me
but i i'm below two i'm
i'm gonna say two to eighty uh for feta
i think that's it but somebody could
check and let me know
anyways um yeah yeah i agree b6 bishop
b7
is kind of the idea for black because
you got to figure out what to do with
your bishop your bishop ain't coming out
of there unless white were to take it
and whites also should start to do
something in the queen side so first
thing first i think bishop d3 should
come pretty soon
this rook would try and come okay we're
definitely doing short castle
and then what else probably
idea i mean i'm not i'm not that
comfortable with drug c1 at the moment
you could try to do other things with
bishop d3 queen c2 you could try to
start push over here that's another idea
so yeah
well yes but we're not talking about the
exact
move order right now we are just kind of
talking about
well where to put the where the pieces
belong so whenever
as soon as you figure out where the
pieces belong you should have an easier
time trying to
place them there but anyways um all kind
went with
rook c1 c6 bishop out
take take and now
um this is kind of like
last year played knight d5 uh super this
is also funny i i've always wanted to
talk about this
i think i will talk about it next time
about the alpine defense
um there is this there is this one line
and this is not it
but that from black side when you play
against the queen's gambit there's this
cute knight e4
that's a lost gear gambit actually i
don't think it's a gambit it's not
really a defense either
so um i've always known it as the last
gear opening
so i'll show that to you that's actually
pretty fun i think i've talked about it
before but yeah
this is exactly exactly thank you pastor
pastor of muppets uh this is kaba
blanca's freeing maneuver
yeah good job take take
knight out knight back to f6 um
this was also possible but then light
goes to g3 and no more e5
and white and black and wants to try and
push for this e5 anyways
exactly castle take and
um we are in another like i think this
is
a very common opening like i don't think
there is anything super new in it
compared to the previous game that we
saw
uh you could try and take here's why but
then there's like knight e5s and that's
also
not super pleasant i would assume
yeah there's nige sorry there's like
knight gf5
and um there are i mean whiteness is
still playing there's nothing wrong with
any
anybody's position but i think it might
be a little easier to go knight f5 first
oops knight f5 first and then you take
that
knight e5 and now right to
any suggestion of what to do with the
bishop
uh i'm annie i don't know
man i don't even know my own racing
think i keep track of ben simons or
anybody else's or anything
i don't know she's a sleeping ray thing
yeah i think we should simply go bishop
back to b3 not
d3 just b3 yeah let's just keep the
bishop safe
and this pretty cool diagonal um
take volume you have to take and
now you are in a position as black that
you have to decide should i try and
exchange queens or should i try and run
what do you think black should do
teaches a sleeping rating it's
definitely 2700
is meowing for food drinking is again
2700.
um he's very very cuddly
that is like 3 000 at this point
but he's also very um
i don't know i think the only thing i
wish he would
improve a little bit was when he goes
outside
he kind of like doesn't really come back
as fast as i would like him so i have to
go like chase him
that's another thing i would um hope for
him to improve that's just a little bit
maybe i go out come back every 10
minutes give me a meal go again
um so interesting how people don't
really want to exchange queen
that is what last year did he did an
exchange coin but he should have
he should have tried to exchange queens
because well
this is i mean this is not the very
place pleasant end game especially
because knight's going to d6
but understanding that this end game is
better compared to your chances with
queen v6
is very crucial um
yeah so what do you guys think what do
you think we should do as white after
queen goes to b6
so one thing that i would like to
mention about alafine
is that he is he had that like
art of finding attacking squares
for his queen if that helps a little
so i see the idea of queen b6 was wrong
queen c7 was better
but it's the same thing i mean you can
if white could still just
try to persuade you to exchange and then
work d1 and you get to this exact same
position
as if you had taken this queen initially
so point b6 now what oh queen d6
yeah exactly i think you should simply
go for this queen d6
and uh your idea is that well i mean
first of all you're second and knight
second of all you're improving your
queen third of all
you could uh already have ideas on the
king
not exactly midnight e7 maybe
but you could think about knight h6 like
if knight goes to g6 ah
knight h6 you take it uptake on f6 and
i'm beginning to poke around in your
pink right
so uh
black simply played the knight to d7
protecting the other knights now white
stimula what do you think we should do
hi nice okay so i see the idea between
g3
i think when g3 is very interesting but
maybe slightly premature
queen g3 right now just g6
maybe or
no i think windy 3 is actually
interesting now i think windy 3 would
have
um been should have yeah i think mg3
also
should be okay
but in the game uh white took
just made a small difference of literacy
one
first and the idea is that okay i'm
gonna do this for d1 now i could want to
go
queen to g3 so you're like you're not
exactly
showing your hand for those of you poker
players
um but white is actually forming a very
strong attack so yeah
i wouldn't worry about how to attack
just like the move order of it
all right so rick d1
and in the game um black actually
rook d8 which was a wrong move black
should have played something with like
queen b5 or queen a5
just trying to poke this knight so like
if you played queen a5 for example
um i mean you're just trying to attack
this knight just a little bit
and you could potentially try to swing
it to the queen side so
sorry king side so i think that's the
only thing that would have been
a little bit more engaged because right
now black
black queen is just just weird not
really doing anything
so rook d1 rook d8
now finally queen g3 has adjusted a
little bit ago
g6 and now what do you think we should
do as
white and
i'm going to give you guys about 30 30
to 40 seconds because
this is a very interesting position i
don't want you to just tell me oh let's
find knight h6 let's play 97.
i kind of want an idea like i want to do
this with the idea this with the idea
that's like
a simple plan and you kind of already
know that you have a small advantage
so shouldn't be too complicated to find
it
so none of the moves that i've seen so
far is even remotely correct so
guys take your time take your time
i'm not saying knight h6 you won't win
but i'm saying it's not really i mean it
doesn't really
it's not really their plan
um bishop f7 king f7
knight there's six just king goes to g7
you just gave up the bishop
um queen h4 maybe but clears for just a
g takes
f5
oh rook d6 isn't there knight e4
i don't really like this idea of my c4
because even if you try and exchange i
mean even if you try and
take stuff over there oh hold on there's
a king of sheep ouch
gosh yeah then you're gonna actually
lose the wreck
huh interesting there's a queen takes g6
and then you can do perpetual huh maybe
i mean if you really want perpetual rook
t6 maybe
uh rook d4 the problem is knight c5
attacking the bishop you want to
exchange the rooks even if you like try
and
run with the rook take over here
and just
what if i just take over here you don't
really have a clear plan
so guys let's take let's take our time
let's take a minute
without typing just try to try to think
really think we've already eliminated
bunch of these moves
i see the correct move being mentioned
earlier but
i would like more people to land on it
before i say it because this
is this is a great critical position you
get to this position and then you're
like okay
now what you know you have advantage but
then now what of it is very very
important
i see the idea of knight h6 you want to
take f7 but that's not going to work
your knight is much more valuable than
that rook on f8
nope whoa this position is really
getting you guys
so two people
so far that i've seen have said the
correct move earlier
but i really don't want to
give it up so i see that you guys are
talking about some ideas to get to h6
square but exactly thank you thomas
queen g5 is the best
idea i see two other people have
mentioned it
i think it was almost and
uh kristen yeah i think those two so
good job
mean it's it's not a super hard move
because you just want to go give
checkmate
and queen g5 is also putting pressure
queen g5 is also also
putting pressure on that rook queen g5
is also
bringing the closer you can do more
stuff with the knight
so queen g5 is a great move overall it's
not just about
this attack and this mate so coin g5
uh in the game last year just played
king h8
to avoid a bunch of checks but now white
just gets knight d6 now f5 is
getting uh poked black plays king to g7
[Music]
now whites to move this is a very
brilliant move
what do you think we should do as white
i mean daryl yeah i'm glad you're
listening and you're learning
but i want more i want more i want moves
i want moves i want
ideas about patterns i want checkmates
and the cat is still passed out what did
he eat
my neck could use a nap myself
uh jesse yay jesse's teaching right
after me
he's great
so i see your ideas but i am
gonna have to say sydney wins this move
of e4 good job yeah e4 is great because
the idea of e4 is that you simply want
to play e5
so you're you're doing the classical uh
you're doing that i did i told you that
it would be great if you could do a mix
of strategic and dynamic
you're not you're not really leaving any
soldiers behind
so you're just going for e4 you just
want to do e5
now if your opponents uh if your
opponent is like
you know oscar plays like knight g8 then
you can start
to uh bring some other pieces to
the third
so rook d3 um you could you could also
just play e5 i guess
that's another possibility you could
just go for rook c3 that's also
super duper cute cutely winning
but um rook d3 is what alejand chose
and after that now actually
black made a horrible mistake black
plays f6
right to move what should we do keep in
mind this f6 is to stop
e5 but when you play f6 you open up like
a whole different can of worms
so why to move how can white punish
black for this
horrible move
uh-huh i know we have six is pretty
horrible but
how can we punish what oops how can we
punish black
exactly yeah
all right so i see a lot of my dead
fives but would you guys
please tell me the full line my top five
king has to go to sj that's not the
question then wise
yeah exactly thank you um
sorry knight f5 queen g6 and yeah there
you go
you take the checkmate you don't take
there is another checkmate
so yeah
no i think that is a pretty uh pleasant
way to finish a game with queen on g6 is
pretty awesome
but basically yeah force mate all right
guys
um this was pretty cool um feel free to
find these studies on leeches our
religious account
and i saved them under the um let me go
backwards so if you go to the studies
and you just look for the
the latest one that i have dorset d for
december 4th
ah it doesn't actually show let me
resize this real quick
if you do that uh all the all the this
one
up here these are the ones that i've
been showing and i also showed a bunch
of these in
the puzzles that i showed on friday
classes for the end game and tactics so
feel free to just
go use these these are pretty cool um
stuff and it's open to public so just
go on the leeches our leashes account go
to the
just love account and yeah the studies
and you should
you should be able to find pretty easy
all right with
that note i'm gonna leave you to go hang
out with
ah what's the link um so that's actually
a
good question let me just try and drop
the link
oh where do i go from here
ah can i actually i'm working with two
different accounts
oh my god you guys are gonna see my
youtube oh
this is gonna be fun actually let's just
go here
all the weird things i've been watching
on youtube oh my
ah i can't send it
why can't i send it all right i i'll
just email it to
um i'll just email it to
ben and this should be
doable all right uh let me close this
part
i don't know i probably should have
emailed this to ben a little bit earlier
but yeah i'm emailing it to you now
ah never mind you found it okay great
great
i don't know why it didn't let me um i
don't know why i didn't let me
paste it okay great awesome so here's
the link for that too
the last two games are the ones that we
looked at today
and feel free to uh scroll through the
puzzles and
um just enjoy them otherwise have fun
with jesse tell him i said hi
and i will see you guys on twitch
channel on friday
alright thank you